This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Oh, there's a horse. And this is front of the show Sean Cole. And it was 39th and 11th. And Manhattan. And there's a horse. A horse-drawn carriage, of course. There aren't just random horses wandering around Manhattan.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。噢，那儿有匹马。这位是节目前奏的肖恩·科尔。当时是在第11大道和第39街交汇处。在曼哈顿。那儿有匹马。当然，是马车。曼哈顿可不会有随处乱逛的马。
They're probably where at some point. I am actually going to meet a woman to talk about cows. It's hard to believe now. Now this area is really industrial. There's a busty poe. But this part of Manhattan, the westernmost part, between say 34th and 39th streets. This was cow country. So we're talking the late 19th, early 20th centuries. You had cattle being herded across 12th Avenue, which is now the Westside Highway. Nicola Twilly is a woman I wanted to talk to about cows. She writes a blog called Edible Geography. There are pictures of 12th Avenue showing the cattle here, showing cowboys, which is crazy.
它们可能在某个地方。我其实正要去见一位女士谈谈牛的事。现在很难相信了。现在这个区域非常工业化。这儿有个busty poe（地名）。但曼哈顿的这一部分，最西端，大概在第34街和第39街之间。这里曾是养牛场。我们说的是19世纪末、20世纪初。当时牛群会被赶过第12大道，也就是现在的西侧高速公路。尼古拉·特威利是我想要谈论牛的女士。她写了一个叫《可食用地理》的博客。有第12大道的照片显示了那里的牛群，还有牛仔，这太疯狂了。
Get a long little doggie. And cows were brought to this part of town, to be made into beef. You've heard of the meat packing district? Well, this was like the meat hacking district. It was nicknamed Abitwar Place, and it was a hive of bone boilers and hide stretchers and large renders. So this, if you can picture it, One boilers and hide stretchers and large renders.
赶走那只小狗。牛被带到城里的这一部分，是为了做成牛肉。你听说过肉类加工区吗？嗯，这就像是肉类切割区。它被戏称为“屠宰场广场”，是骨头锅炉、皮革拉伸机和大型提炼机的聚集地。所以，如果你能想象一下，骨头锅炉、皮革拉伸机和大型提炼机。
So this, if you can picture it, would have been a disassembly line for every single part of a cow. The cows would be ferried across the Hudson River from New Jersey, on a cow boat and land at the dock here, and at first, you know, marching a few cows across 12th Avenue to the slaughterhouse was fine. You can hold up traffic for that. But then came more cows and more cows. And more folks in their carriages and then the train came through and cars.
所以，如果你能想象一下，这本该是处理牛身上每一个部位的拆解线。牛群会从新泽西州通过哈德逊河，乘牛船到达这里的码头。起初，你知道，赶几头牛穿过第12大道去屠宰场还可以。你可以为此拦住交通。但后来牛越来越多。人们的马车也越来越多，接着火车开过，汽车也来了。
All of a sudden, cows are in the way. I mean, cows move at a different pace. And so there were reports of epic cow jams on 12th Avenue. What does a cow jam look like? That sounds horrible. I know. I think it was just people felt like, you know, the pace of cows and cowboys and cow-drowing on 12th Avenue
突然之间，牛成了障碍。我的意思是，牛的行走速度不同。所以有报道称第12大道上出现了史诗级的“牛堵”。“牛堵”是什么样子的？听起来很可怕。我知道。我想人们只是觉得，你知道，第12大道上牛群、牛仔和赶牛的速度。
was no longer suited to modern life. So. So, so. This is what we're here to talk about today. I cannot wait. Me neither. Here we go That's why people invented things like the cow tunnel
已经不再适合现代生活了。所以。所以，所以。这就是我们今天来谈论的话题。我等不及了。我也是。开始了。这就是为什么人们发明了像牛隧道这样的东西。
Cow tunnel cow tunnel. Oh, it's the best Let's hear it again cow tunnel. Cattle tunnels Say it again cow tunnels Whenever you say it, it's funny. I know. I mean, you have to love them. Cow tunnels. Cow tunnels. In Manhattan.
牛隧道，牛隧道。噢，太棒了。让我们再听一遍，牛隧道。牛隧道。再说一遍，牛隧道。无论你什么时候说，它都很有趣。我知道。我的意思是，你一定会喜欢它们的。牛隧道。牛隧道。在曼哈顿。
Or as Nicola called them in a piece she wrote for Gismoto, the lost cow tunnels of New York City. And when Nicola says that people invented things like the cow tunnel, for the purposes of this story, that really could mean one of two things. Either people invented the tunnels to march the cows underneath 12th Avenue to the abattoir, or people invented this crazy cock and bull story about the cow tunnels. More bull than cock in this case. Because everybody loves a good vaguely plausible urban myth. And so, Nicola Twilly has been on a years-long quest to figure out whether the cow tunnels
或者正如尼古拉在为《Gizmodo》写的一篇文章中所称的那样，纽约市失落的牛隧道。当尼古拉说人们发明了像牛隧道这样的东西时，为了这个故事的目的，这实际上可能意味着两件事之一。要么人们发明了隧道，把牛赶到第12大道下方的屠宰场，要么人们编造了这个关于牛隧道的疯狂的荒诞故事。在这种情况下，荒诞成分多于真实。因为每个人都喜欢一个模糊可信的都市传说。所以，尼古拉·特威利多年来一直在寻找牛隧道是否。
ever actually existed. Because, after all, the idea of cows loathing along under your feet in New York City, at least how we think of New York City now, is insane. And this is a woman who writes a blog that's generally about food and place. And if anything exists at that same intersection, it is the cow tunnel. I just a dedicated infrastructure for animals like that. It's a new genre of architecture. Exactly. The cow tunnel. When you think about all of the tubes and tunnels and weird things that are underneath the street,
真的存在过。因为毕竟，在纽约市，至少在我们现在认为的纽约市，牛在你的脚下漫步的想法是疯狂的。这是一位写博客的女士，内容通常关于食物和地点。如果那个交叉路口真的存在什么，那就是牛隧道。我只是觉得这是一种专门为动物设计的设施。这是一种新的建筑类型。没错。牛隧道。当你想到街道下面所有的管道、隧道和奇怪的东西时，
we have tunnels for cars, we have tunnels for subways, we have all these tubes filled with electrical cables and the internet and all this. I mean why shouldn't the cows have their own subterranean infrastructure too? Nicholas first happened on the cow tunnel story by chance. So I was reading a book called Raising Stakes by Betty Fassel. It's Fassel, actually. Stakes, of course, is spelled S-T-E-A-K-S.
我们有汽车隧道，有地铁隧道，我们有所有这些装满电缆、互联网等等的管道。我的意思是，为什么牛不能有它们自己的地下基础设施呢？尼古拉第一次偶然发现了牛隧道的故事。所以我当时正在读贝蒂·法塞尔写的《提高赌注》。其实是法塞尔。当然，“Stakes”（赌注）拼写为S-T-E-A-K-S（牛排）。
Yes, the kind that could be Porter House or, yeah. Or T-bone. Exactly. Or Sirloin. Any of the above. Striploin, rump. I like sang rump. Exactly. Skirt.loin, rump. I like saying rump. Exactly.
是的，那种可能是波特豪斯牛排，或者，是的。或者T骨牛排。没错。或者西冷牛排。以上任何一种。腰肉，臀肉。我喜欢说臀肉。没错。裙边肉。我喜欢说臀肉。没错。
Skirt. And she's reading along, and there was this one little passage on page 22. You could miss it quite easily if you are reading too fast. It's a sort of two-line thing. And she says, traffic was so heavy in the 1870s that a cow tunnel, in quotation marks, was and capitalized actually. Was built beneath 12th Avenue to serve as an underground passage, and it's rumored to be there still, awaiting designation as a landmark site.
裙边肉。她读着读着，第22页有一小段话。如果你读得太快，很容易错过。那是一种两行左右的东西。她说，1870年代交通非常拥挤，以至于在第12大道下方修建了一条“牛隧道”（加了引号，实际上还大写了）。作为地下通道，据传它至今仍在那里，等待被指定为地标遗址。
And then she just carries on, you know. As late as 1880, Horowitz writes, blah, blah, blah. That's what, that's literally one sentence. Exactly. And I thought that's weird. I wonder if they're still there. So I googled it. And then what did you find? I found Brian Whippred.
然后她就继续写了，你知道。直到1880年，霍洛维茨写道，等等等等。那是什么，那简直就是一句话。没错。我想这很奇怪。我想知道它们是否还在那里。所以我谷歌了一下。然后你发现了什么？我发现了布莱恩·惠普雷德。
I think is how he pronounces his name. Yeah, that's how I pronounce it. Brian Whippred is a utility specialist for whitelinger associates in New York. It's a structural engineering firm. What I do for wideling is figure out how to get from point A to point B underground in New York City. Like if Khan Edison is cutting a trench for electrical cables, they need an navigator. As well as investigate all kinds of anomalies and strange things that they find underground when doing digs.
我想他是这样发音他的名字的。是的，我是这样发音的。布莱恩·惠普雷德是纽约怀林格联合公司的公用事业专家。那是一家结构工程公司。我为怀林格所做的是弄清楚如何在纽约市地下从A点到达B点。比如如果联合爱迪生公司正在为电缆挖掘沟渠，他们需要一个导航员。以及调查在挖掘时发现的各种异常和奇怪的东西。
So Brian went searching for the truth about cow tunnels more than 10 years before Nicola. In 1997, he published an article in a local, local newspaper called the Tribeca Trib, which is what Nicola found in her web search. The headline was, Bum Steer. I will summarize it here. Brian's talking to a con-ed worker named Fred. Just Fred, no, last name. And Fred says he was watching a work crew install a new drainage basin downtown,
所以布莱恩在尼古拉之前10多年就开始寻找牛隧道的真相了。1997年，他在当地一份名为《翠贝卡论坛报》的报纸上发表了一篇文章，这正是尼古拉在网络搜索中发现的。标题是《蹩脚的牛》。我在这里总结一下。布莱恩正在和一位名叫弗雷德的联合爱迪生员工交谈。只有弗雷德，没有姓。弗雷德说他当时正在看一个工作组在市中心安装一个新的排水盆，
which is, by the way, nowhere near the side of those old slaughterhouses. They dig and dig, and then finally they hit this kind of wooden barrier, wooden. They break through it, and it's hollow on the other side, and then a quote unquote old man from the neighborhood steps up and says, Why see you found the cow tunnel? So Brian walks the story around, asks a whole mess of people, and everybody's heard of the cow tunnel, but when they talk about it, the facts are never the same.
顺便说一句，这离那些旧屠宰场的地点很远。他们挖啊挖，最后他们撞到了一种木制屏障，木制的。他们打破它，另一边是空的，然后一个来自社区的“老头”走过来，说：“噢，你看，你找到了牛隧道。”所以布莱恩到处打听这个故事，问了很多人，每个人都听说过牛隧道，但当他们谈论它时，事实从来都不一样。
But A, it's somewhere different, and B, it's made of different items, and C, it was built at a different time. And when Brian finally circles back to Fred, Fred says, well, actually, I never saw it. It was a buddy of mine who saw it. So again, that's how Brian told the story in his article in 1997. Sitting in his office with me in 2014, he told it this way. We were digging some test pits for Verizon. Wait, but so you were there and digging and...
但A，它在不同的地方，B，它由不同的材料制成，C，它是在不同的时间建造的。当布莱恩最终回到弗雷德那里时，弗雷德说，嗯，其实我从来没见过。是我一个哥们儿看到的。所以，这就是布莱恩在1997年的文章中讲述这个故事的方式。2014年他坐在办公室里和我交谈时，他是这样说的。我们当时正在为威瑞森挖掘一些测试坑。等等，所以你当时在那里挖掘，然后……
Right, and so we dug down about five feet and there's this brick and curved surface that looks like a vaulted roof. So now the story has completely changed in Brian's mind. Suddenly he's the one watching the work crew, not Fred. And in this telling, the blockage they hit while digging is brick, not wood. And he talked this way for another 10 minutes before he finally stopped and said, wait a second.
对，我们向下挖了大约五英尺，那里有一个砖砌的弯曲表面，看起来像拱形屋顶。所以现在这个故事在布莱恩的脑海中完全改变了。突然间，他成了那个看着工作组的人，而不是弗雷德。在这个版本中，他们挖掘时撞到的障碍物是砖块，而不是木头。他这样说了10分钟，直到他终于停下来，说：“等一下。”
You know what? You sort of caught me in the beginning of this because I was like, gee, I could have sworn I saw it and then you're just like, you know what, I'm thinking back to the article. I didn't. So I knew it was the same damn thing Fred did, aren't I? Yeah. I want to tell you how big it is and where it goes. I see cattle tunnels every day, man.
你知道吗？你刚开始的时候确实抓住了我，因为我当时想，天哪，我发誓我看到了它，然后你就像，你知道吗，我在回想那篇文章。我没有。所以我知道这和弗雷德做的是同一件该死的事，不是吗？是的。我想告诉你它有多大，它通向哪里。我每天都能看到牛隧道，伙计。
There's one over there. I know, I started doing the same damn thing. This is what happens with the cow tunnels. And why the truth of them is so hard to get a hold of. It's like as soon as you start to retell the story, it gets loose and begins to bend. It's like an instant fish tail, except it's about cows. And somehow, the folklore of it just stretches further and further out until nobody can remember how the story started. And so when Nikola Twilly wrote her first blog post about the cow tunnels in 2010, she went solely off of Brian's article, which uncovered nothing, and that one line in the Betty
那边有一个。我知道，我开始做同样该死的事情了。这就是牛隧道发生的情况。为什么它们的真相如此难以掌握。就像你一开始重述这个故事，它就变得松散并开始弯曲。这就像一个即时的鱼尾，只是它是关于牛的。不知何故，它的民间传说越传越远，直到没人记得这个故事是怎么开始的。所以当尼古拉·特威利在2010年写下她关于牛隧道的第一篇博客文章时，她完全基于布莱恩的文章，那篇文章什么也没发现，还有贝蒂·法塞尔书中的那一行字。
Fussell book. But around the same time she hit publish, a little shred of hard-ish evidence popped up, the cow tunnel version of the Shroud of Turin. It's a coffee table book, called New York in the 19th century. You have it here. Yes, and there's a picture in here that shows this is an 1877 engraving from Harper's weekly of a cow tunnel at 34th Street. Cattle being driven up through a tunnel looks like a wooden tunnel and it says tunnel
但在她点击发布的同时，出现了一点点硬证据，牛隧道版的《都灵裹尸布》。那是一本咖啡桌书，叫《19世纪的纽约》。你这儿有。是的，这里有一张照片，显示这是1877年《哈珀周刊》上关于第34街牛隧道的版画。牛群被赶过隧道，看起来像是一个木制隧道，上面写着“来自码头的隧道”。
from the dock. Huh? Emerging from it's almost like from the tunnel and there's a cattle in there with a little whip keeping them moving. And they're strung up by one foot and it's so merely executing. Yeah, and then exactly and the rest of the pictures get kind of gruesome. But wow, so that seems to be evidentiary. Right, there's a picture of a cow tunnel and it's like, okay.
哈？从隧道里出来，几乎就像是从隧道里出来的，里面有一头牛，还有一根小鞭子让它们保持移动。它们被一只脚吊起来，这简直是处决。是的，然后没错，剩下的照片变得有点可怕。但哇，这似乎是证据。没错，有一张牛隧道的照片，就像是，好吧。
Well, I don't know about that though. This is Nicolattilly again. I mean you can't actually see Where the tunnel is. There's a cow emerging from a tunnel. It's an engraving not a photograph But there's a cow emerging from a tunnel. Well and the cowboy in the picture is about two-foot tall So there's all kinds of problems with it. The cow was about ten times his size. So I don't know. I wasn't I wasn't buying it. I needed more. I needed more. So she did what she says bloggers like her never do when they're researching a topic. She called people. I talked to the city's director of archaeology and she sort of let out this
不过我对此不太确定。这是尼古拉·特威利。我的意思是，你实际上看不出隧道在哪里。有一头牛从隧道里出来。这是一幅版画，不是照片。但有一头牛从隧道里出来。嗯，画中的牛仔大约两英尺高。所以它有各种各样的问题。牛大约是他的十倍大。所以我不知道。我没买账。我需要更多。我需要更多。所以她做了她说像她这样的博主在研究主题时从不做的动作。她打电话给别人。我联系了市考古局局长，她发出了一声叹息，好像她以前没听过这个问题一样。噢，真的吗？好吧，在我第一次写关于它们的内容后，它在一些博客上冒了出来，我想那些人确实在做他们的工作并给她打了电话。她可能对他们说了对我说的同样的话，那就是没有证据，从来没发现过任何东西。那位女士说，你为什么不和格林威治村历史保护协会的负责人谈谈？他们保护了肉类加工区。
sigh as if she'd be not this question before. Oh really? Well after I wrote about them the first time it sort of bubbled up on a few blogs and I suppose those people were actually doing their job and called her. And she had said what to them probably what she said to me which was no evidence never found anything. And the woman was like, why don't you talk to the head of the Greenwich Village Society for Historic Preservation? They got the meat packing district preserved.
所以我们和他谈了，安德鲁·伯曼，非常好，非常抱歉，抱歉，没有牛隧道的证据。天哪，我知道。所以我正准备把这些东西完全当作神话，这时我决定给历史视角公司的C.C.桑德斯打电话，她基本上为大型项目、建筑项目等提供咨询。他们评估该地区是否有历史、考古、重要的东西。这就是为什么我……这就是为什么我……是的，这是我对外行的简化理解。她从史泰登岛回来的渡轮上给我回了电话。她刚做完一次挖掘。噢，它们当然存在。是的，毫无疑问。就像，别荒谬了。我一到家就把蓝图发给你。经过这一切，竟然有蓝图？是的。我现在没有原件，
So we talked to him, Andrew Burman, very nice, very apologetic, sorry, no evidence of cow tunnels. Geez, I know. So I am about to really fully write these things off as a myth when I decide to call C.C. Saunders of historical perspectives incorporated, which basically consults with big projects, construction projects and that sort of thing. And they gauge whether there's historical,
但我有我们放入报告中的副本，那是我们在研究9A公路（也就是西侧高速公路）重建时做的。这不是C.C.桑德斯。没错。我是法琳·施奈德曼。我从来都不是C.C.桑德斯，但我已经和她一起工作了大约26年。
archaeological, important stuff in the area. That's why I... That's why I... Yeah, that's my dumbed-down layman's take on it. She calls me back from a ferry on the way back from Staten Island. She's just been doing a dig. Oh, of course they exist. Yeah, no question. Like, don't be ridiculous. I'll send you the blueprints, soon as I get home. After all this, there are blueprints? Yeah. I don't have an original at this point,
桑德斯说法琳基本上是他们店里的“牛隧道专家”。所以早在1991年，州政府就委托历史视角公司对第12大道和30多街上方的那个前肉类加工区进行历史研究。这是州政府考虑重做9A公路的时候。法琳写了这份报告。所以她做了大量的研究，
but I have the copy that we put into our report that we did when we studied the reconstruction of Route 9A, otherwise known as the Westside Highway. This is not CC Saunders. Correct. I am Phaleen Schneidermann. I have never been CC Saunders, but, I am Phaleen Schneidermann. I have never been Ceci Saunders, but I've worked with her for about 26 years.
查看了所有这些旧地图和文件，并构建了第12大道沿线曾经存在的结构图景。公寓、仓库、牛隧道。停在那儿。在法琳关于那个肉类加工区的报告的最后一页，第28页。你能读一下上面写什么吗？当然。嗯，宾夕法尼亚铁路公司建造并使用了一条地下牛通道。它延伸了大约200英尺，
And Ceci said Phaleen was basically the cow, Taneleon at their shop. So back in 1991, the state contracted historical perspectives to do an historical study of that former meat packing area at 12th Avenue in the upper 30s. This is when the state was looking to redo Route 9A. And Feline wrote the report. So she did a ton of research,
在第12大道和海岸线下方，通往西38街和西39街之间的街区。原谅我1991年糟糕的语法。它并不是说它在第12大道下方200英尺。它是200英尺长，在大道下方。这个位置修饰语。隧道建于1932年，可能仍然存在。等一下。1932年。我知道。那很晚了。是的，你知道那是城市里所有这些建设正在进行或至少在规划的时候，新的桥梁和隧道。汽车越来越多，你仍然有牛需要从码头到屠宰场，这样纽约在漫长的一天建设结束后，
looked at all these old maps and documents, and built up this picture of the kinds of structures that used to be along 12th Avenue there. Tenements, warehouses, cattle tunnels. Stop right there. On the very, very last page of Philean's report about that meatpacking area, page 28. Could you just read what it says? Sure. Well, an underground cattle pass was built and used by the Pennsylvania Railroad Company. It extended about 200 feet
晚餐能吃上牛排。那么它有多大？隧道，9英尺宽，7英尺高。这是从纽约码头管理局许可证号Manhattan.673-a确定的。哇。是的，所以。这看起来相当铁证如山。嗯，是的，我会说它不是铁证如山，是混凝土证如山，但是的。真的能看到蓝图。再次是尼古拉·特威利。这简直是一个，你知道，
beneath 12th Avenue in the shoreline to the block between West 38th and West 39th Street. Pardon my bad grammar back in 1991. It was not meant to say that it was 200 feet beneath 12th Avenue. It was 200 feet long and beneath the Avenue. This place modifier. The tunnel was built in 1932 and may still be present. Wait a minute. 1932. I know. That's late. Yeah, and you know that was during when all of this Construction is going on in the city or being planned at least new bridges and tunnels Cars or more and more a factor and you've still got cows needing to get again like two hundred feet from the dock to the slaughterhouse so that New York could at the end of a long day of building
中彩票的时刻。我感觉相当不错。这就像找到了亚特兰蒂斯失落之城的蓝图。没错。没错。我的意思是，它真的，我的意思是，我非常兴奋。那你当时怎么想？嗯，真的，我想我必须去那里挖一下。所以我们大约在这里。在查看了蓝图后，尼古拉停了一会儿写了一篇新的博客文章，然后去了隧道所在的地方，
Have steak for dinner. so how big was it? The tunnel, 9 feet wide by 7 feet high. And that was ascertained from a New York Department of Docs permit number Manhattan.673-a. Wow. Yes, so. That seems pretty ironclad. Well, yeah, I would say it wasn't ironclad, concreteclad, but yes. To actually see a blueprint. Again, Nicola Twilly. It was sort of a you know
看看是否还有任何迹象，任何它可能仍然存在的希望。有些人发誓它是完整的。不是隧道完整。是隧道完整。人们说如果我们能在其中一个码头，在其中一栋建筑里找到入口，而不必挖掘道路本身，我的意思是，我不知道。我的意思是，有西侧高速公路的建设。
a lottery-winning moment. I felt pretty good. It's like finding like the designs for the law city of Atlantis. Exactly. Exactly. I mean, it really, I mean, I was pretty stoked. And so what did you think then? Well, really, I thought I have to go out there and dig. So we're roughly here. After looking over the blueprints, Nicola paused for a minute to write up a new blog post and then went out to the area where the tunnel had been
嗯，你想到贾维茨中心。当你想到林肯隧道中心，当你想到我们正站在旁边的林肯隧道时？很有可能。如果曾经有过牛隧道，它在所有的建设中都被粉碎了，任何空隙都被填满了。等等，所以你有一份它的蓝图？
to see if there might be any sign of it, any hope that it might still exist. Some people swear it's intact. Not the tunnels intact. That the tunnels intact. People have said that if we might be able to find an entrance in one of the piers, in one of the buildings without having to excavate the roadway itself, I mean, I don't know. I mean, there is the West Side Highway construction.
那你怎么知道它真的建成了，而不是仅仅被规划了？它在后来制作的该地区的其他地图上。噢，天哪。它在陆军工程兵团1953年的港口系列中，我不太知道那意味着什么，但它就在那里。事实上，在她的研究中，尼古拉发现了第34街那条出现在《哈珀周刊》照片中的另一条隧道的证据。有一篇1875年的《纽约时报》文章谈到了它。
Well, you think about the Javit Center. When you think about the Lincoln Tunnel Center, when you think about the Lincoln Tunnel, that we're standing right next to? Most likely. If cow tunnel there was once upon a time, it was pulverized in all of that construction, and any void was filled in. Wait, so you have a blueprint of it?
它说，第12大道下方有一条隧道，动物们被带进屠宰场。事实上，牛群从登陆到被转化为牛肉，外面的公众从未见过它们。这就是最有趣的地方，这是一个如此关键的时刻。我们开始与食物的来源完全脱节。这些是，你知道，城市正在变成某种神秘且隐形地被喂养的东西，就在这一刻。而且显然在波士顿还有另一条具有历史意义的牛隧道，也没人知道它是否存在。
So how do you know it was actually built instead of just planned? It's on other maps that were made of the area later. Oh, oxy. And it's in the 1953 port series from the Army Corps of Engineers, which I don't really know what that means, but there it is. And actually in her research, Nicola found evidence for that other tunnel at 34th Street that was in the Harper's Weekly picture. There's this New York Times article from 1875 that talks about it.
恰恰相反，尼古拉·特威利。恰恰相反。等等，现在的火车正穿过曾经是牛隧道的地方？不。我们确实知道波士顿的牛隧道是否存在，它确实存在，只是它在马萨诸塞州的剑桥，我和查理·沙利文站在它上方的一座桥上。这个社区的发展方式是，牛市很早就建立在马斯特萨瓦诺，在铁路通过之前，农民会把牛赶过道路来到这里。
It says, there runs a tunnel under 12th Avenue where the animals are brought into the shambles. In fact, the cattle are never seen by the outside public from the time of their landing until they are converted into beef. And that's what's so interesting, it's such a pivotal moment. We are beginning to become completely detached from where our food comes from. These are, you know, cities are becoming things that somehow get fed mysteriously and invisibly at this precise moment. And apparently there's also one other cow tunnel of historic importance in Boston that also no one knows whether it exists or not.
查理是剑桥历史委员会的负责人。他说这座桥（沃尔登街桥）的两侧曾经有牛栏，还建了一条牛隧道，叫“沃尔登街牛通道”，这样农民就可以把牛从一个栏赶到另一个栏。他们不想让它们在沃尔登街上乱跑，所以……因为它们可能会……因为它们会跑掉。就像，松散地跑。走到哈佛广场去喝卡布奇诺。
O-contrare, Nicola Twilly. O-contrare. So wait, the train right now is going through what used to be a cow tunnel? No. We do know whether the cow tunnel in Boston exists, and it does, except it's in Cambridge mass, I stood on a bridge up above it with Charlie Sullivan. The way this neighborhood developed, the cattle market was established over on Master's Savanoo quite early, before the railroad came through, and farmers would drive their cows here over the roads.
噢，牛？对。是的。牛有自己的想法。总之，这条牛隧道现在被列入国家史迹名录。但除了提到它的一块牌匾外，你永远不会知道它藏在铁路桥下，禁止公众进入，旁边是一条活跃的铁路线，被围栏围起来，以免人们被火车撞到。
Charlie's the head of the Cambridge Historical Commission. He says there used to be cow pens on either side of this bridge, the Walden Street Bridge, and a cow tunnel, called the Walden Street Cattle Pass, was built, so farmers could drive the cows from one pen to another. They didn't want to let them loose on Walden Street, so... Because they might... Because they would get loose. Like, loose-lose. They made like, walk loose. Walk into Harvard Square and have a cappuccino.
所以简而言之，委员会保护了一个没人能看到、没人能进入的结构。没错。唯一的方法是跳，试着跳过那个围栏。你想那样做吗？会很有趣。那会很有趣。度过一个早晨的有趣方式。
Oh, cow? Right. Yeah. Cows have minds of their own. Anyway, this cow tunnel is now on the national register of historic places. But other than a plaque that mentions it, you'd never know it was tucked underneath the railroad bridge, off limits to the public, next to an active rail line, which is fenced off, so that people don't get hit by trains.
我不确定我能不能做到。好吧。没关系。所以，但请随意。请告诉我你没带他跳过围栏。请告诉我你没带他跳过围栏。听起来不会太美妙。所以，当查理完全看不见，不能被指控协助和教唆时？是的。
So in short, the Commission preserved a structure that no one can see, no has any access to. Correct. The only way is to hop, try to hop that fence. You want to do that? Be fun. It would be fun. Interesting way to spend a fence. You want to do that? Be fun. It would be fun. Interesting way to spend a morning.
当查理完全看不见，不能被指控协助和教唆时。是的！我进去了。像弗林一样。我爬下这个陡峭的堤岸，穿过所有这些灌木丛。噢，天哪，就在这儿。我能看到它。牛隧道。噢，天哪，这太令人兴奋了。
I'm not sure that I'm able to do it. Okay. That's okay. So, but feel free. Please tell me that you hop the fence without him. Please tell me that you hop the fence without him. It's not going to sound too wonderful. So, when Charlie was well out of sight and couldn't be accused of aiding in a bedding? Yes.
它基本上是一个砖穹顶。原始砖块，来自1857年。噢，伙计，它上面覆盖着涂鸦。被一扇黑色的大门挡住了。哞！没有回声。哞——！没有回声。《99%隐形》牛隧道本周由肖恩·科尔制作，山姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。我们是旧金山91.7当地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心制作，出自Arxine办公室。
when Charlie was well out of sight and couldn't be accused of aiding in a bedding. Yes! And I am in. Like Flynn sort of. And I climb down this steep embankment through all these thickets. Oh my God, here it is. I can see it. The cow tunnel. Oh Lord, this is exciting.
一家建筑公司，如果指针上升，他们会为你设计你见过的最美丽的牛隧道。牛隧道。如果你喜欢这个节目的故事，你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Tumblr上获得更多更多更多。但99pi.org上会有牛隧道。Radio to PiO。来自P.R.X.
It was basically a brick dome. original brick, from 1857. Oh, man, it's covered in graffiti. Engaded with a big black gate. Moo! No echo. Muuuuuh! No echo. Cow Tunnel 99% invisible was produced this week by Sean Cole with Sam Greenspan Katie Mingle, Avery Truffleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced in beautiful downtown Oakland, California out of the offices of Arxine.
你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
An architecture firm who, if the needle rises, will design you the most beautiful cow Tunnel you've ever seen. Cow Tunnel. If you like the stories on this program, you can get more and more and more of them on Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr. But there will be cow tunnels at 99pi.org. Radio to PiO. From P.R.X.
一家建筑事务所，如果需求增加，他们会为你设计出你见过最漂亮的牛隧道。牛隧道。如果你喜欢这个节目的故事，你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Tumblr上获取更多。但牛隧道的图片会在99pi.org上。Radio to PiO。来自P.R.X。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。